But uh thank you for joining. What's uh
what's on your mind?
Um a lot a lot right now. But on this
topic,
uh uh are you like exclusive to what's
in the background or just what you've
been talking about? Yes. Yeah. Did did
Jesus preach Christianity or Islam? I'd
like to get into this.
Okay. Um my I have a question to start
that. Do you believe Jesus was a
Christian? No, I believe that he is the
founder of Christianity.
Were people who were around him, were
they considered Christians? Yes.
Did they ever call themselves
Christians? Yes.
Can you show me where they called
themselves Christians? Yeah. So, you
have if we go to the Epistle of Peter,
Peter says, "If you suffer for being a
Christian, you know, rejoice
um when you suffer as a Christian."
Um, let me
see. See
here. Bible verse.
And by the way, the so-called pe
Muslims, I don't know if you call them
Muslims that are calling calling you
names and stuff, that's not that's not
Islam. That's the stupid people. That's
not Islam.
Well, um I would beg to differ, but
that'll be another conversation if Okay,
we can get on that topic afterwards.
Sure. All right. So, this is first Peter
chapter 4 verse 16. It says, "However,
if you suffer as a Christian, do not be
ashamed, but praise God that you bear
that name.
That's first Peter chapter Peter 4,
right? 16.
Okay.
So, can we look at the context of this?
Who is he who is he talking to or about?
He's talking to believers. believers,
you know, fellow Christians, fellow
believers in the Messiah, um, who are
undergoing persecution, who are undergo,
you know, certain trials and
tribulations and, um, simply for being a
Christian, being a believer in Christ, a
follower in Christ. And so he tells them
like, don't don't be ashamed. Matter of
fact, you you praise God that you are
even identified as a Christian, you
know, so wear that proudly.
Um, I've read parts of the Bible. I've
never read the whole Bible. So, I'm not
going to talk about parts that I haven't
read because I'm not going to say
something that I haven't read. Okay.
Um, I just don't I don't believe that
Jesus himself referred to himself as
God. I know you guys say, "I am the
father in one. No one can get through
the Father except through me."
Um, can you kind of like
explain why you guys believe he's God if
he says stuff like that? Not directly, I
am God, worship me. Cuz I know a lot of
Muslims using debate say, "Oh, he said,
I am God, worship me." So, uh,
uh, they say that he doesn't say that.
Yeah. So, I mean, what's what do you
guys understand from those vers or those
verses? Well, it's um it's a stu it's a
stupid argument to say, "Oh, um show me
where Jesus said," I am God. Worship me
in those words or else he did not claim
to be God. The reason is this is called
the exact word fallacy where you are
demanding exact words as if the concept
or the implication can't be there from
another statement. So like for example,
if I were to say um I have students and
I give them lessons, what am I claiming
to be?
teacher. Exactly. I didn't have to say I
am a teacher and I you know ex So you
get the point. So So basic so really the
question is it's a good question is did
Jesus claim to be God? That's a good
question. The answer is yes. And then
the question should be how did he claim
to be God? Right? So Jesus doesn't have
to say the words I am God in order for
him to claim to be God. He can say
things that only God can say and that
clearly communicate that he's God. and
that's how he claims to be God.
Um, yes. But so I I've also seen parts
where like it says Jesus bowed his head
or um
Yeah, let's just go on that. So like
parts where it said Jesus bowed his head
on the floor. Mhm. So if he were to be
God and um like you say and just what my
point is is like he I understand what
you mean like again like you said I have
students I I'm a teacher but then
there's parts where
basically um what's the word I'm looking
for?
Um basically say that he show that he
isn't if that makes I forgot what I
forgot the word. I can't really brain
fart right now. It's okay. I I
understand what you're saying. saying
that there's parts in the Bible where
Jesus seems to be uh communicating that
he's not God. That's what you're saying.
And so, yeah, I would say that um that's
just that would be just simply a
misunderstanding. Um because there's
never ever anywhere where Jesus
um says he's not God and not not in
those words, but like where he
communicates that he's not divine,
right? He he never denies his divinity
in any way. Um what you do see is that
Jesus is a humble servant to the father
who sends him and um him being a humble
servant like having the role of a
servant doesn't take away what he is in
his nature being being God as long with
the father. So distinct with the father,
humbly submitting to the father and
taking on flesh and walking amongst us
and um you know living in his role as
the humble servant of the father doesn't
take away from his his divinity.
So before he became the flesh was he one
with God? Yes.
And then he came down he came down in
flesh came down in flesh is is still one
with the father. He still has the same
divine essence, but then he also has a
human nature now.
Yes. But if if we look at Matthew, it
says that he fell to his face to the
ground and prayed to the father. To the
father. But he is one with God though.
So why would he pray to the father, not
just to himself? Well, if so prayer is
communication, right, with God, right?
So that's that's what we're seeing. And
if so, because God, and when I say God,
I mean I'm just talking about simply the
divine essence. Because the divine
essence consists of three persons, the
father, the son, and holy spirit. They
all share the same divine essence and
from eternity's past have been united in
one with each other, communicating with
each other, fellowshipping with each
other from eternity's past. So when
Jesus comes in flesh in visible form,
we're seeing that visible fellowship,
that visible comm communion that he has
always had with the father from before
even the world was created. So him
praying to the father or communicating
with the father is not a problem. It's
just showing the relationship. The
father does the same thing with the son.
Okay. So what is he my my question is
again why doesn't he just communicate to
himself? Why pray? Who the father? Who
who who talks to themsself?
A lot of people. Everybody I'd say.
But I mean like in a serious matter like
who you know maybe you know like I got
to talk myself down sometimes like you
know Avery calm down. Don't go off on
those Christians who keep coming up. But
but really like a real conversation. If
he's fully God why is he talking to
another part that's also fully God? Well
there's another person. Why would there
need to be
I understand, but why would there need
to be something he can't just fix
himself because he's fully It's not It's
not something that he just uh it's not
about him fixing fixing himself. It's
about him um carrying out the plan and
as the humble servant of the father, he
carries out the plan. He executes the
plan.
Okay. So, I want to go back to that part
where the Matthew Matthew 26:39. I'm
sure you're familiar with it. Sure.
Uh uh there you go. He fell with his
face. Do you have somebody with you? No,
I'm by myself. Okay, go ahead though.
Okay, go ahead. Uh going a little uh
farther, he fell with his face to the
ground and prayed, "My father, if it is
possible, may this cup be taken from me
yet not as I will, but as you will."
Mhm. So when it what I don't understand
is why he distinguishes himself
different from him and the father cuz
they're different persons. So the son is
a person and the father is another
person. So they're distinct in their
personhood yet united in their essence
as the one God. Yes. But wouldn't
wouldn't they just need to have wouldn't
they just be one if they were God?
They're one God. They're one divine
essence. So these are these are two
different things. separated that's why I
don't understand okay what what do you
understand person to be
um well there's in different essence but
I mean I'm a person you're separate
person right so like for example so an
essence or being is what you are right
it's it's it's your state of existence
what you are so what you are is a human
being right that's what I am as well
we're both human beings who you are the
person you are is uh What's what's your
name? Is it Cal Callus? Calli. Calli.
Callie. So Callie is who you are. Who I
am is a is Avery, right? So we're two
different human beings and two different
persons, right? Let's like show a
distinction between being and
personhood. For example, a rock. A rock
is a being. It has an essence, right? It
has a state of existence. Would you say
that a rock has personhood?
No. Right. So a rock has being, right?
It has an essence but it doesn't have
personhood is there's no uh rational um
you know intelligence to it. When we go
up the ladder humans human beings that's
what they are that's a human being and
human beings each human being has one
person right. Yeah. When we go up to God
we're talking so the God what what God
is the divine nature the divine essence.
He's a divine being. We're saying that
this divine being has three persons. the
father, the son and the holy spirit. So
this one divine being exists as three
distinct persons unlike humans who are
only one being one human being and one
human person. The divine essence is one
divine being that has three divine
persons with sh that share that one
nature. But why why would God need to be
separated into three? It's not separated
just showing a distinction because well
like really a good answer to this is is
that God is he's the most he's the
greatest conceivable being that we can
think of right he's unlike his creation
at all right no I 100% God cannot be
created we all know that and he's and
he's beyond creation like what creation
is he's right and so out of the he's out
of the realm of creation and and when
and when it comes to virtues and
qualities he's the greatest in in every
quality and every virtue, right? When it
comes to mercy, what love, what I never
understood is is the is the three. Yeah.
I'm I'm trying to break it down. I'm I'm
trying to I'm trying to break it down
why it's necessary for God to be
multi-personal. Um rather than a
singular person who has just, you know,
one divine essence, right? That's what
I'm agree I wouldn't agree they're one
because if one if they were one, they
would all know the same thing. And I'm
sure you can already you can already
figure I'm sure you're jumping to
something else right now. So do you do
you want to do you want to know why it's
necessary for God to be multi-personal
or do you want to know if Jesus
continue? Go ahead. Yes. Go ahead. Okay.
So the reason why it's it's it's uh
necessary for God to be multi-personal
is because God is the greatest
conceivable being. Right? We already
agree with that. So God for example when
it comes to love, God is the greatest
when it comes to love. He has the
greatest form of love. Would you agree
with
that? Oh, I lost
him. I lost
him. Oh
no.
Callie. Callie, come
back. You were the only real guest that
I've had so far.
Okay.
Well, well, that's that. Let's bring up
uh let's bring up someone else,
man. Let's bring up somebody else.
But because God is love and he's the
greatest, he has the greatest form of
love. God has to have
multi-persons because love requires the
greatest form of love
requires multiple
persons. So God being love within
itself, God within himself would have to
be multiple persons.
Or else if he's not, then that would
mean that he would have to rely on
something outside of himself in order to
have the greater forms of
love, which would mean that he is now
dependent on
creation. So it's necessary for God
within his own essence to be
multi-personal so that he doesn't have
to go outside of himself to have the
greatest form of
love, i.e.
God must be triune.
Francisco, how you doing? Are you a
Muslim?
Oh, I didn't mean to get on here. My
bad. I don't know how I got on here.
Oh, you have
a I think that you did that on purpose.
How you doing? How you doing? You a
Muslim?
Yeah. Awesome. So, what do you think?
Did Jesus preach Christianity or Islam?
Uh Jesus raised Islam and not
Christianity, but people misunderstood
him and that's how Christianity came
into life, you know. Okay. Can you show
me uh Jesus preaching Islam?
Man, for example, just think about it.
So, what's the closest religion to
Christian?
The closest religion to Christianity.
Yeah, just Christianity. There's nothing
close to it. I guess the closest thing,
I guess, would be Judaism, but they're
way off.
You say Judaism? Yeah. Tell me how.
because they affirm the Old Testament
and hold to the Old Testament.
I mean, do they believe in Jesus? No,
you asked me the closest.
I mean, but I'm saying like, do they
believe in Jesus? I just told you no,
which is irrelevant because you asked me
the closest religion to Christianity,
man. So, if if they really don't believe
in Jesus, so that means they're not
anywhere near Christianity. Because as a
Christian person, would you um
say uh someone that don't believe in
your God is closest to being really you
you basically asked me to pull out of a
a botched batch. All of the batches are
botched. All of the choices are bad.
None of them are close to Christianity.
But if I had to pick the closest out of
these religions in the world that's
closest to Christianity, it would be
Judaism because they hold to the
prophets.
Well, what about Islam? No, you guys
don't hold to the prophets. You reject
them all.
You said we reject them all.
I mean, we do believe in the prophets,
which is the I mean, Jesus is one of
them. We believe in him and we don't
believe him as a god or son of God.
believe him as a prophet. Yeah. Which is
why which which is why I say you reject
the prophets because they taught that
the Messiah is God, the son of God, the
son of the prophet. The pro the prophets
you say that you talking about the
prophets like John and Lucas and all
them in the Bible. I'm talking about
Isaiah and Malachi and Moses,
Zachchariah,
Daniel, these guys.
Well, like I said, people misunderstood
uh misunderstood Jesus because the only
thing Jesus or the only thing every
prophet that came into this world was
preaching is Islam. Can you show me that
uh I mean Muhammad uh prophet Muhammad?
No, not Muhammad. Not Muhammad. I know
he preached Islam. I'm saying Jesus. Can
you show me that Jesus preached Islam?
I mean who who uh who did Jesus get his
um his book from? Do you do you mind
showing me that Jesus preached Islam,
brother?
I can't show you right now. I'm not on
my PC. Yeah, I am. I'm I'm on it. Where
Where you want me to go? Do you want me
to pull up uh like a scripture
reference? Go to um
go to where?
Hold on. Hold on.
cuz there is this uh one
chapter that Jesus himself said that he
is not the father and
that's true. He is not the father.
Yeah, he's so he's not the father. So
why would you worship him instead of the
father that created him? Well, he
doesn't say that he's created either.
So, but he did he did he did tell us to
he told us to honor he told us to honor
him the same way that we honor the
father
I mean which what you mean he didn't say
he was created I mean he's a human being
I think I think you're missing what what
I'm saying here Jesus said for us to
honor him we have to honor the son the
same way that we honor the
father so we we we worship the father
right we hon we honor the father through
worship obedience prayer Right.
Mhm. That same honor, worship,
obedience, prayer, we have to give to
the son as well. That's what Jesus says.
But they're separate. They are distinct,
not separate.
So is that is that is that is that
preaching?
Is that hold on, brother. Is is that an
Islamic message for Jesus to say for
Jesus to say that we are that he's the
son of God and that we're supposed to
honor the son the same way that we honor
the father? Is that is that an Islamic
message?
Nope. Jesus never said um I'm the son of
the father or whatever you just said. I
mean I'm not I'm not trying to be I mean
that's in
your um Yeah. So So where do you get
where do you get what Jesus said? Where
do you get it from?
I mean it's in a book uh in a kab in the
Quran if you read I mean if you ever did
your research on the Quran you could see
all the the the words of Jesus and
everything. Okay. So so give me
something. Give me something. What did
Jesus teach?
Jesus u peace and love. Okay. For
example the Quran says that Jesus
mentioned somebody named Ahmed to come
after him. Right. Muhammad. Yeah, be
correct. Yeah. Where did Jesus ever say
this?
Where can I find Jesus actually saying
this? Because the Quran says he said it.
So where can I find Jesus saying it?
Well, I didn't finish the Quran. So I
cannot point you somewhere that I really
don't know. I can but so I'm here to
help, brother. The Quran doesn't mention
the Quran doesn't say so. It doesn't
give you a reference. It just makes a
claim and just says Jesus said this
without a reference. Have you ever read
the Quran? Yeah, you're talking to a
shake, bro.
You're not no shake. But I'm just saying
you got to find out.
Have you ever read the Quran and like
not not to be not to what do they call
to find some for some mistakes or
anything, but to be open and to learn
about what the religious I was open in
seeing what the Quran itself says and
its themes, its messages, its context.
Yeah.
So, you're saying you read the Quran and
you're still So, do you are you able to
engage with what I'm saying, bro? It
sounds like if you haven't read the
Quran and you're a Muslim, I don't I
don't see how we can have this
conversation.
I I did, but I'm So, where did Jesus say
this?
If you read the Quran, brother, please
don't waste my time, brother. Where did
Jesus say what the Quran says he said?
Where can I find Jesus saying that?
Where would I go?
Man, I mean, I all I'm going say is I
feel sorry for you. I mean, if you read
the Quran and you still a disbeliever,
that's good for you. I'm a disbeliever
because I read the
Quran. He he ran
away. You Muslims,
man. All I got But I got to say, man, I
feel sorry for you, man. I feel sorry
for you. If you read the Quran, you
still didn't believe it. I feel sorry
for you, man. I was for you. You You
read the You read the Quran. You You
read the Quran like seeking truth. You
read the Quran seeking the
truth. Nah, there's no way you could be
a disbeliever if you if you read the
Quran. You finished You finished the
Quran? Nah, I Well, I haven't read I
haven't read the Quran. Totally. But I
still know I know the I'm a believer
though. I haven't read the Quran. I'm a
believer. But you read the Quran and
you're not a believer, bro. That show
that you I feel sorry for you. I didn't
have to read the Quran to
believe. I didn't have to read the Quran
to believe. But you read the Quran and
you're a disbeliever. I feel sorry for
you. Imagine that. Muslims, y'all don't
have to read the Quran to believe. But
if you read the Quran, you become a
disbeliever.
Hi. Hi. My name's Avery. I've read the
Quran and I'm a
[Laughter]
disbeliever. Oh, shoot.